DevOps a set of practices to build test
and release your code in small frequent
steps one of the core practices of
DevOps is continuous integration which
has developers commit their code to a
shared repository often on a daily basis
each commit triggers an automated
workflow on a CI server that can notify
developers of any issues integrating
their changes when a repo evolves in
small steps like this it prevents what's
known as merge Towel imagine Mary you're
back and developer builds a new API for
your product
shortly after Jane your front-end
developer starts work on a new UI a few
months later when it comes time to merge
their features we find that they're
completely incompatible the build fails
and we now have to spend a bunch of time
and money resolving these conflicts
let's go ahead and build a continuous
integration pipeline now to see how it
prevents issues like this here on github
I have a node.js web app in order to
deliver this out to my customers I need
to run three commands test build and
deploy I can automate this entire
process in the cloud by using a CI
service like github actions first I
create a workflow and then I tell it to
run on every push to the master branch
the event triggers a job that runs on a
Linux container in the cloud and we tell
the container what to do as a series of
steps first it checks out the code in
this github repo then sets up nodejs
installs my dependencies and runs my
tests
build and deploy commands now anytime we
commit code to the master branch in this
repo it will run this workflow if any of
the steps fail the bad software won't be
delivered to our customers and will
automatically know there's an issue that
needs to be addressed at the end of the
day CI CD offers two main benefits it
helps you automate things that would
otherwise have to be done manually by
developers that will increase your
velocity but it also detects small
problems early before they can grow into
major disasters and that results in
higher code quality this has been C ICD
or DevOps in 100 seconds make sure to
hit the like button if you want to see
more short videos like this and stay
tuned tomorrow for a full dead loss
project using github actions thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one